hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
if you're like me you remember maybe in
high school maybe in college in some
psychology course being taught about
Abraham Maslow's hierarchy of needs
there was a sort of pyramid diagram and
at the bottom of it
there were your basic physiological
needs food shelter things like that then
you built up through other sort of
higher-level psychological needs until
at the top you reach self-actualization
so today's guest Scott Barry Kaufman is
a psychologist who is proposing that we
update Maslow's hierarchy of needs he's
done two things number one he's actually
dug into many of the writings that
Maslow himself did and learned things
like Maslow himself never do a pyramid
and Maslow himself had a lot of ideas
that go well beyond the famous hierarchy
of needs and the second thing that Scott
does is propose an entirely new metaphor
based on a different kind of hierarchy
he thinks that the pyramid metaphor is a
little bit stationary and it gives you
the idea that there's just something to
achieve that would make us once and for
all self actualized so Scott's idea is
that instead what we should aim for is
not self-actualization but transcendence
and the metaphor he uses for this is not
a pyramid but a sailboat
there's the hull of the boat which has
some of you more basic needs and then
there's the sails of the sail boat which
have more dynamic needs and I kind of
like this imagery because as a physicist
as someone who knows about entropy and
the arrow of time in the big picture and
elsewhere I've absolutely emphasized
that we should think of life as a
process as a series of changes
inevitable changes things like happiness
which are very popular are a little bit
overrated because we get the idea that
you can just achieve happiness and stay
there and life is not like that so Scott
and I talked about different ways of
being psychologically healthy the
different needs that he's identified the
empirical research that he's used to
identify these needs and I push back a
little bit so I don't agree with
everything he says but you know what
that's psychology we're not anywhere
near done it's not a mature field in the
way that particle physics or cosmology
are so that gives us a little bit of a
way to think about ways that we could
do better in understanding who we as
human beings really are how we can live
our best lives I should also mention
that Scott has his own podcast called
the psychology podcast he was lucky
enough to get that name early on where
you can find him talking to a bunch of
professional psychologists about these
ideas and a whole bunch of related ideas
remember you can support the mindscape
podcast on patreon if you go to
patreon.com/scishow age which is
preposterous universe calm slash podcast
different ways you can support on
patreon giving one dollar two dollars or
whatever per episode and in return you
get ad free versions of the episodes and
you also get the ability to ask
questions at the monthly ask me anything
and we've changed the policy so now the
answers to the monthly AMA go public so
everyone can listen to them but if you
want to actually ask them and get your
question answered you should join
patreon today with that let's go
[Music]
Scott Barry Kaufman welcome to the
mindscape podcast
oh thanks Adam I've been looking forward
to this chat for a while you know I
thought while thinking about this chat
that in some ways psychology is as
ambitious as physics and cosmology right
like physics and cosmology tries to
understand the whole universe which is
very big but psychology tries to
understand people which are very
complicated the idea of writing a book
that actually gives useful advice to
people living their lives and how they
think and things like that it's a
daunting task so before we get into
before we even get into the details I
mean what are your thoughts about the
hubris of being a psychologist and
trying to help people with psychology
okay sure yeah so I think in a lot of
ways one could make the argument that
studying humans is more complicated than
studying the universe oh yeah I get more
complicated well let me ask let me
elaborate because I really bizarre
fighting words perhaps for you know
physicists but I think that you know in
some ways humans are more unpredictable
then you know that we get the Sun you
know you get the Sun okay the Sun
rotates yeah that's fine okay no no okay
but um you know we we get we get how the
universe works in some ways right and
there's a certain predictability or a
regularity there right mm-hmm
but my gosh studying humans is so
confusing because we first of all
there's individual differences and as
you know that's the area that I focus on
yeah mostly I'm fascinated with human
variation and when you start looking at
individual differences then it's kind of
like all bets are off in a sense so some
psychologists focus just in the
universals and that may give us a false
sense of predictability about humans but
then you say well well what if we look
at the variation in the u.s. oh my gosh
like these these general principles
really break down because you have this
a-hole who broke all the rules it's like
like with the universe you don't have
that many a-holes you know who like get
out of line when you have the equation
that's beautiful when you cope with a
beautiful equation right
right yeah no I mean this is why it's
not fighting words at all like I think
the physicists and cosmologists be the
first to agree that studying human
beings is way more complicated I mean
that's the beauty of physics is that it
actually is at heart super simple and
elegant and pristine but but aside from
so so we totally agree that human beings
are complicated and hard so what gives
you the sort of you know how do you get
through the day telling yourself and
nevertheless I have really good insights
to share with you all yeah especially
with all these replication crisis is
happening and right and the fact that a
lot of things are aren't coming out well
I think that it's more it's just there's
a spirit and excitement of let me share
with you what we discovered but I think
that you have to have that humility as a
psychologist to not say we've we've
found it once and for all in in any sort
of way and and and not have such
confidence that people can't change as
well you see there's a lot of research
on what is and I think there's a dearth
of research in psychology and what could
be you know there are there are people
to try to do interventions and a lot of
interventions don't work but you do see
this tendency especially like in the
intelligence field for instance there's
been no good intervention I'm gonna say
this you know right now there's been no
really strong intervention that has
dramatically improved IQ scores and
intelligence researchers there's a bunch
of intelligence researchers who almost
get a Glee from that finding which I
don't understand why there's a Glee for
it you know but almost a sense of like
see we told you intelligence you know
none of that doesn't change but then
it's it's pretty genetically determined
you know or influenced very heavily
influenced and and and yet I still want
to maintain the spirit of oh that's
interesting well let's just keep what
trying here like like we shouldn't it's
not like we just stopped trying to do
intervention it's just because we
haven't been able to find the one that
that really had a striking effect yes
you're interested in the sort of the
engineering and technology side of
psychology as well as the science
descriptive side of techni of psychology
yeah I think equally which makes me
weird
and not only weird but it makes me it
makes me have a fight with in a civil
war within myself because I have that
was a phrase Mazal used easy you notice
in terms of like trying to become
integrated human beings you know like we
need we need to transcend that civil war
within ourselves these these different
sides of herself that are fighting each
other but you know I have the scientist
hat and when that hat is on in full
force it does not really like the
intervention hat sir side of myself and
when the intervention side of myself is
on I'm like I'm not really into the
scientist that much so it is it is an
interesting sort of balance that I then
I try to strike within myself
well you mentioned Maslow tell us about
Maslow's we're gonna go into your new
book this is coming out called
transcendence is that right that's it's
called transcend transcend suburb got it
transcend is it is it like an order
you're giving people please transcend
yes yes that's the idea it's an action
you know action word for sure it's it's
a hopefully an inspirational Northstar
kind of book that kind of shows what
humans could be well and it builds a lot
of the work of Abraham Maslow so tell us
a little bit about who he is I mean we
all we've all heard of him but Phyllis
in is if we didn't know oh good I'm
really glad you said that because I've
had other people Billy well no one's not
good good no see Maslow is why should
anyone care about your book uh my thanks
I like your attitude about that everyone
knows him as well I think most people
who've taken an introductory psychology
class who have taken an introductory
management class have come across
Maslow's writings yeah for sure I've
come across at least II never even heard
him as well have come across that iconic
pyramid now so Abraham Maslow was a
humanistic psychologist sorry the
pyramid is the hierarchy of needs that
we're talking about correct Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and it's usually
depicted as a pyramid where you have an
order of needs that must be met before
one can become everything they're
capable of becoming so which is labeled
self-actualization now this is the story
this is the car this is the story that's
being told to so many introductory
psychology management students and
people who
see it diagrammed on the internet
however it turns out that mass will
never drew a pyramid and and there are
so many misconceptions about the
hierarchy of needs it's it's incorrect
how it's been taught the past 60 years
direct a list of needs a hierarchy but
he has never drew them in the form of a
pyramid correct he never conceptualized
in that way his theory was very
developmental he made it very clear that
we are constantly in this dynamic of
moving two steps forward and one step
back that we can also that we can we can
target multiple needs simultaneously we
don't have to wait to start self
actualizing until everything else is
done until we check all the boxes and
also it's is I like to say in the book
later life is not a video game it's not
like we reach one level of the hierarchy
like connection and then some voice from
above is like Congrats you've unlocked
esteem you know Mortal Kombat or
something yeah it's just nuts not the
way the world works and NASA was very
clear about that so I really tried to
infuse the spirit of what Maslow
actually meant as well as the rest of
the humanistic psychologists it really
is an attempt more globally in this day
and age in this world today to bring
back a lot of the ideas of the
humanistic psychologists I've been lost
but tell us what the hierarchy is what
are the levels the original model it met
and I revised it I revised it but in the
original model you had the safety needs
our sir he even had below that you had
physiological needs okay like food water
shelter and you had safety needs need
for a certain sense of predictability in
your environment and then you have
belonging in love and he lumped them
together which I've teased them apart
and we can talk about that in my my
revised model but he had love and
belonging together and then he had
esteem needs which is esteem from others
he was a lot become self-esteem it's the
esteem in others holding both I would
say he has two such components of that
both esteem for mothers as well as their
own self esteem but the problem with
that is it's hard to actually
disentangle that because we do draw so
much so to our own self-esteem on these
demos it's almost like redundant in like
90% of humans
then and but then you can get to the
self actualized individuals so that's so
that's the next level of self
actualization so there is a big it's a
big leap it's I've always viewed that is
quite a jump I'm like okay I feel you
know really pumped up ego wise boom I'll
give self actualized I I you know this
seems to be a lot of steps along the way
there and in a lot of ways that's what I
try to do in my book is connect those
dots and and I mean I took self
actualization out as a stage it's not
because we it's not like we ever reach
that late again life it's not a video
game it's not like you ever reach
self-actualization esteem but
self-actualization I'm betting most
people heard either directly or
indirectly from Maslow's hierarchy of
needs can you tell us a little bit about
what he meant by that I concept Maslow
talks about in different ways but there
is one one quote he he used if you give
me a moment to actually find it I really
love this quote it was the best
description of self-actualization I
could find okay sure so I found a
unpublished essay that he really wanted
to publish it was he was calling it
critique of self-actualization this was
really his attack he really wanted to
publish this before he died and instead
it was left in an unpublished collection
but this is the quote and I think this
is this really gets the heart of what he
really thought about self-actualization
we try to make a rose into a good rose
rather than seek to change roses into
lilies it necessitates a pleasure in the
self actualization of a person who may
be quite different from yourself it even
implies an ultimate respect and
acknowledgement of the sacredness and
uniqueness of each kind of person so in
a lot of ways he viewed
self-actualization as being able to real
it's that unique part of your human
potentiality that is unique to you
because these other forms of these other
needs these basic needs that I mentioned
are things we all share and we're all
striving toward but the the focus of
self-actualization is more and realize
that unique potential potential
potential within you that is in a lot of
ways some people would call it your best
self you know in modern day language
other I don't like that phrase yeah
because I you know I think that there's
no such thing as the real self well I
actually really don't like to phrase the
real self because there's no such thing
but you know but you know I think that's
really what he was getting at was this
this unique full potential of what we
can offer the world and and I do think
he there are misconceptions about it as
being selfish
so David Brooks you know the New York
Times columnist it was hating on Maslow
and I called a couple years ago and I
was like oh hello even though you update
him you're you know yes definitely yes
tradition I view him as a good friend
yeah you know who I've never met yeah
you know and and I do think as Maslow
did Maslow thought thus to that we could
have friends that from prior generations
hñ bit creepy but we could really have
such a fondness for someone and get to
know them so well I mean I I met his
Mozilla's daughter only remaining
daughter and granddaughter granddaughter
Jeanne who he had written about lovingly
in his personal journal personal Diaries
Jeanne was three years old when Madeline
Maslow died but he would say that Jeanne
was the greatest source of my peak
experiences in life and I killed me that
knowing that I won't be able to live to
see how Jeanne turns out so it was such
a peak experience for me to meet Jeanne
you know and and and and she's looking
at me as we're talking I'm geeking out
over her grandfather and she's like my
gosh you know so much more about my
grandfather that I know I even care to
know about there was something there was
something about that where I really made
me feel connection to him even though I
never met him if that makes sense
yeah no absolutely at a time when many
of us are sticking close to home this is
a great opportunity to learn new things
and a wonderful way to do that is with
the great courses Plus this is an app
that gives you online access to a huge
selection of lectures from the great
courses usually I mentioned physics
courses on here but there's a whole
bunch of other things you can
think about there's a course on an
introduction to infectious diseases to
learn about viruses and vaccines and
disease transmission there are courses
on money and banking on fighting
misinformation on a number of topics in
science history math gardening cooking
yoga and so forth and with the great
courses app you can listen at any time
from a phone a tablet or an
internet-connected TV and now is a
perfect time to start because mindscape
listeners are getting a great offer of a
free trial plus when you sign up for a
quarterly plan it will only be $10 a
month to get access to all the courses
from the great courses plus so sign up
today at this special URL the great
courses plus comm slash mindscape that's
th e great courses PLU s calm slash mind
scape start learning today but the
important good so that is very helpful
to understanding self-actualization and
i do want to move on to your version of
this so i don't spend too much time but
I do want to tease out the idea that
it's a hierarchy because this is both
important but also can be overdone and
caricatured right the idea that it's a
hierarchy being that first you solve all
your physiological needs or secure them
and then then you go on to safety and
then you go into a love etc and is that
the way it works is that the way Maslow
thought at work is that it is that a
good way of thinking about it no not
that we must a hundred percent satisfy
something before we can go on to the
next that would be a misrepresentation
he argued at any given point in time
well there's a certain percentage
certain fraction of each of those needs
that we have satisfied so right now I
could ask I could go down the list with
you and ask you you know maybe you're
sixty percent connection maybe you're
90% esteem yeah Twitter followers maybe
you're you know very high in safety and
and then some other need you know this
if we talk about some of my needs that I
added and we could go down the
percentages so I think he made it clear
that at any given time we can target
multiple needs simultaneously we're not
at a hundred percent on any of them
however he did argue he did make the
case there was a hierarchy of prepotent
is what he called it and whenever I use
that word in people what are you talking
about my try to use that word my book my
publisher like no one's going to a
potency means well
now what does he mean by that well I
think he are he did believe that there
certain needs that are he called
deprivation needs when we're deprived of
these things they they shift our entire
worldview and and narrow you know sense
they narrow our worldview to a
particular worldview and they really do
make it harder to be all that we could
become which is self actualization so
they really do get in the way of self
actualization and I think that is quite
right I think that what he really
emphasized is not this lockstep
progression of the of a triangle you
know of like something that you had to
climb like a mountain you climb but more
of like an integrative process mmm-hmm
where if you don't have well integrated
some of these deprivation needs the
whole system is really going to be out
of whack if that makes sense yeah no it
actually does it does make sense but
okay so I think so there but there's a
hierarchy in the sense that in Maslow's
view some of these needs are a little
bit more basic even though you don't
100% satisfy them before moving on as I
think you correctly point out there is
there are levels they're not just a list
in random order yes there are levels
which could be our I don't think that a
firm scientific ground we can say that
the precise there is a precise order
because there's individual differences
there are cultural differences in which
of those are more proponent than others
we could probably all at the very basic
level say that things like food water
shelter yeah are essential I think well
you know there's some things that are
they're hard argue universally but there
are some cultures where esteem might be
more important than connection or
cultural connection my brother's what I
really wanted to emphasize was was this
this distinction between I didn't wanna
get hung up on the precise order but I
wanted to talk about the dialect the
Adventura Singh dialect dialectical
between security and growth mmm-hmm and
that's really what what Maslow was was
fascinated with was that
electical and that leads us directly
into your reimagining of it so you've
thrown away the pyramid - boring -
stationary usually have a new metaphor
yes so I think a sailboat offers at
multiple levels so to speak a difference
a better conception of what it means to
live a good life or what it means just a
little tear just what it means to live
life period you know we're all in this
vast unknown of the sea we're all
traveling in our own direction but we're
all in kind of the same sea of
unpredictability we don't know when
there's gonna be waves coming we have to
secure our boat as much as possible
before we can go anywhere if there's a
leak in our boat if where there's severe
deprivation 'z we're not going anywhere
hmm but once we can do that we can feel
safe and comfortable to open our sail
and and and and and how we open our sail
also affects how where we can go and how
fast we can go and all these things so I
really think that the sail boat does a
nice job of capturing that that
interaction between the boat and the
sail or between safety and growth right
so you if I understood it correctly the
hull of the boat sitting there in the
water is the story of our security and
you know these needs that we absolutely
have to have met whereas the sale of the
boat and the air around it is the story
of growth and change and trying to move
through life in the best way we can yes
and at the top of this sail is purpose
and really having a clear clear
direction and being very focused and and
having the whole unit so another thing I
like about the sail boat metaphor is
that it's all about an integration of a
whole vehicle it's the whole vehicle
that travels through the ocean you're
not you're not climbing piece by piece
different parts of you up this mountain
that it doesn't seem to be out humans or
even how thermodynamic systems work like
whole systems are greater than the sum
of the parts
and that's that's a big big thing I try
to emphasize my book because I am into
evolutionary psychology I mean I I went
through a phase of evolution psychology
maybe like 15 years ago where that I
thought it was the cat's pajamas and and
now what I want to do is I want to
really show that humans can be greater
than the sum of their parts we're not
just identified with our modules so I
think there's something that we can use
the evolutionary approach to understand
the the parts of us but I'm ultimately
interested in how the whole organism
deals with those paradoxes of human
existence and and and lives their own
good life in their own way you know how
do they self actualize in their own
direction or asthma so we put it in
their own style and to me that's what's
really really fascinating it about him
is our ability to supersede or to become
greater than the sum of the parts and
this is where the uniqueness of every
person comes in and you want to sort of
emphasize yeah okay no I ultimately one
emphasize transcendence okay well we'll
get there that's like I'm gonna get all
of the layers on the table so I mean
good good good even though you have a
different metaphor for the sail aboard
boat rather than the pyramid you still
have some needs right you still have a
list of needs that we're meeting in the
form of this sailboat do you even call
them needs still or do you have a
different name I do call them needs I
called okay basic I call them human
needs for sure and there is this is I
call this the integrated hierarchy of
needs
the revised hierarchy of revised
integrated hierarchy of needs yes good
yes and so which which are the needs
associated with the hull of the boat
safety which I've combined Maslow's
physiological and safety needs into one
because I think there's so much research
showing that how our body and mind are
so interconnected and it made sense to
talk about a general level that should
you say level I don't know to call it
now you know a general process yeah in
in which
there's a we could be pitched into the
state of psychological entropy the state
of great uncertainty where there's too
much unpredictable in our environment
that our brain really is a full of fear
and anxiety and so that that would be
that stage and that could happen from
hunger it could have happened from
having no food on your on your table
or roof on your head around your head
this me above your head yep - but it
could also be living in environment
where you there's a lot of violence in
your environment that pervades your
environment or there's just things that
are so unstable so that would all be in
under that that aspect and in the
chapter on safety you actually talked a
lot about attachment to other people so
maybe that is not what comes to people's
mind when you first start talking about
safety and it's part of safety is you
know having a house and food and water
but you're also there's that seems to be
I would have put that in connection but
you put it in safety the attachment we
have to other people yes because the
opposite of secure attachment is
insecure attachment when you're in
securely attached there's such anxiety
especially if you're if you have the
anxious attachment style mm-hmm you're
pitched into that state of inserting
value where you don't trust people see I
see Trust as a really core part of this
of this need for safety so coherence in
the environment but also trust that your
environment will be safe to me is a
central part of this this this need so
inability to treat other people like
they're your friends not your enemies
and that you can depend on them in times
of great need yeah see that's what's
that's what attachment theory is all
about can I do I have trust and
confidence in this caregiver when we're
when we're a vulnerable you know and
it's been studied a lot in children but
there also have been a lot of studies
and adults as well
my relationship partner do I do I trust
that when I you know when things really
get tough that that they'll protect and
and help me in those situations and as a
working psychologist you must know I
mean you must be very familiar with all
the different ways in which attachment
is tricky right and we attachment to
other people like and you can be overly
attached you can be clingy right you
want to have that trust and respect for
other people without I don't know
without getting in their way I'm not
sure how you would put it but there's
definitely a balance to be struck there
absolutely so not to get too nerdy about
this but it's better it's really good to
view attachment styles as Continuum's
how not types I think that the this type
way of thinking has not really been very
profitable for psychologists and and we
really need to think about things as and
and this applies to everything I mean
this is this is actually quite profound
I think it a whole revision of the DSM
needs to occur so that could be a whole
their conversation will review
everything all disorders as as on a
continuum but if we view there's two
main dimensions that we all differ on
anxious attachment style and avoidant
attachment style those are the two
fundamental dimensions we differ on and
and and there's no such thing as secure
attachment type none of us are just like
none of us are ever 100% self actualized
none of us are ever 100% securely
attached so if you just have these two
dimensions anxious and avoid an
attachment styles you can actually
create a space of of different
combinations of those two of different
ways that one can be in securely
attached or or you can only and then you
can only conceptualize secure attachment
the extent to which both of those are
high if you should I'm saying so but
explain to us what they are well what is
an anxious attachment continuum and what
is the avoidance well this is the place
to get nerdy go go nuts can I really
good nerdy okay give me a moment I
actually say it sometimes again these
moments where I've never said it better
than I did in the book so can I just
find that or okay so I think so the
anxious
attachment dimension reflects a concern
about being rejected and abandoned and
is abandoned and is the product of
beliefs about whether others will be for
you in times of great need the avoidant
attachment to mention has less to do
with a sense of safety and more to do
with how you regulate your emotions in
response to stress whether you use
others as a secure base or pull away and
withdrawal from them hmm now it's
interesting because I've looked really
closely into the literature and found
something that I think's interesting and
that it's it's much more detrimental in
mental health to score very very high on
the anxious dimension than the avoidant
dimension I found interestingly that
there are a lot of people who score high
on just anxious to share to score very
high on just the avoidance dimension who
are content with their life well it's
gonna say from the description you just
gave it doesn't sound like one end or
the other is clearly good and clearly
bad for the anxious one yeah being
anxious is bad being less anxious is
good but how much of ourselves we secure
through other people seems like there's
a happy middle ground yes I mean there
is a lot of research showing that if
both of those dimensions are very very
low so very you're very well avoidant
attachment very low anxious attachment
it does tend to be correlated positive
with lots of forms of well-being in life
and okay and lots of other indicators of
mental health as well as even epigenetic
research and and how certain genes
become activated and in the stress
response so working as a interaction or
combination I think is interesting but
there are people who aren't very anxious
attachment all but are very high and
avoided and and that's an interesting
combination I think it's been under
studied in the research literature there
there are plenty people were actually
quite fine being single you know not
being in a relationship and we found
we're not we doctor Keltner and their
colleagues that have done some
interesting research looking at
different correlations between these
different attachment styles and
personality traits and they found that
those who score very high and avoidant
but not anxious they just don't score
particular
hi on compassion there's not compassion
and love like they don't report being
very well yeah I'm a loving person but
they actually report higher levels of
contentment into life that's interesting
I think it's interesting so this is a
good point to digress a little bit
because you're mentioning you know the
research that's been done I mean how
much of the conversation we're having
here is based on data is based on
experiments and empirical research
versus how much of it is a theory that
you're hoping will be tested using data
down the road oh my gosh well if I may
if I if I I don't know if I made what I
want to may do but if I may fall to toot
my own horn in a second I really
meticulously tried to make sure
everything I said in this book could be
linked to two robust studies so I have a
pretty extensive references list in the
back a lot of it was yes yeah this was
something that I've been working on for
years and years and wanted to get right
at least as right as could be in in the
moment so when you do when you make
choices like collapsing Maslow's first
two levels into one needs a over it yes
you you but you looked at the data when
you chose to do that it's not just like
an idea you had that sounded cool that's
exactly right
I mean I obsessed over every little
detail of this book for instance I mean
it gets really nerdy I have some I put
the most nerdy things in the footnotes
yeah that like it's like believe me when
I say it like I say something like throw
a lie in the book like and modern
personality psychologists have confirmed
this model of security and growth this
distinction but then I have like a huge
footnote for it for any nerds that want
to go to the back of the book to see
what I'm actually mean and actually link
it to research and research on
cybernetics yes and and research being
done in artificial intelligence not just
in humans I think that there's a whole
there are lots of different areas of
human knowledge that are collecting that
that I think is quite exciting pointing
to this distinction that Mazal put out
that we that a whole system in order for
it to fully to be fully functioning
it needs both the ability to resist
distractions so stability as well as
plasticity the ability to have come up
with new goals so you can get really
there's a level which can get I can like
explain a lot of my decisions at the
nerdiest level what I'm trying to say
yeah let's let's get to some more of the
decisions you're making here so we're
still in the hull of the boat there's
three needs that we talked about in the
hull one is the safety that we just
talked yeah the next is connection what
does that mean yes yes the need for
connection is the need to have at least
a minimal number of intimate mutually
loving or appreciating relationships in
your life so then more than just getting
likes on Twitter correct and this is
this is a point I wanted to make because
I had two sub needs that comprised
connection and that's the need for
belonging and the need for intimacy and
I think a lot of people in the field of
psychology have completed the - or maybe
I've treated them as synonymous but when
I was really looking deep into the
literature on belonging it seems like
they're lots and lots of instances in
which people strive for the need to
belong they may do so in a way that
lacks intimacy so you let's say you join
a violent extremism you know there you
join a cult or a religious organization
or political organization because you
have a desperate desperate deprivation
of the need to belong you and and the
leaders of this thing you joined don't
care at all about you I mean they only
care about you to the extent to which
you're furthering their cause right in
what way is there a reciprocal loving
relationship there so it seemed to me
like both of those things are really
important and also for the loneliness
epidemic it it dawned on me that there's
so much of a deprivation of a need for
belonging that people are going about it
hope in in the hopes that it will
satisfy that hole within themselves of
loneliness and then they're surprised
when it never does sorry is there a
loneliness epidemic
well it I used that phrase then I had
Steven Pinker on my podcast and he's
easily I would not call that he's like
if you look at the history of you I'm
like yeah I get your stick don't get me
wrong he's a he's a friend and then and
all the good things about him but he's
good he likes to take the long long long
view and I'm like yes but that's cold
comfort for the billions of people on
this planet who in this generation right
now this moment of history would quote
would quite characterize it as an
epidemic do you know what I'm saying but
well tell me I mean what do you mean by
the lonely's in this epidemic well
they're the the the rates especially
among the elderly are quite staggering
of reports just simple reports of
loneliness like if you do self-report
questionnaires and you ask people to
report how lonely they are and it is
really high among among the elderly but
you also see it even in college students
you see the the the rates are high-end
and and not just the rates but the
impact of loneliness John Cacioppo I
believe that's how you pronounce his
name he was a loneliness researcher and
unfortunately passed away as I was
researching the book but he had shown
that that the effects of loneliness on
our physical health is is even greater
than smoking or obesity or lots of other
factors that we know are are our risk
factors for but this is but you're
saying that there is a you know
quantitative difference in my loneliness
now versus wet ah last year versus yes
hundred years ago so yes so that is so
that is a if we want to look take the
long long view I could get on board a
Pinker sort of argument that it's not
technically an epidemic because it's
hard to make the case that this
generation is only err then the hippies
were for instance you know in the 60s
and I think there is a point there that
could be made so perhaps we shouldn't it
called and I want to say something as
well because I am very open to being you
know for people making these arguments I
after my podcast chat I had with Steven
Pinker I went back in my book and
actually changed my book and I took I
think I took out the word epidemic
but I'm just trying to understand it is
the claim that loneliness is increasing
or is the claim simply that there's a
lot of it there's a lot of it okay I
want to focus on the oh there's a lot of
it yeah
aspect and I don't want to get stuck too
much on you know making it a competition
of some sort with with with prior epochs
or generations you know sure but I mean
I totally get on board with the idea
there's a lot of loneliness out there
almost by definition it can be hidden
from us because of other people who are
lonely maybe we're not connecting with
them and the effects of it could be very
bad the effects that's also what I
wanted to focus on because I was that
was mind boggling to me to look into
that literature and seeing just how
strong in effect loneliness can have not
just on our minds but also our bodies
and on mortality and it's it's a risk
factor for for death so that's a greater
risk factor than a lot of physical risk
factors that people look at and so
that's where this connection need comes
in this is the second need in the whole
of your Creole boat correct and how does
it relate to the issue of introverts
versus extroverts right I mean we're
introverts are having their day in the
Sun now we have Susan Cole look you know
let us love introverts again because
it's not that they don't like people
it's just they need their own space is
that is that related did this need for
connection somehow one way or the other
I've done quite a bit of research on on
introverts and extroverts dimension but
I actually see that is irrelevant to
this need okay because the need suggests
a minute I said minimal number we're
talking about one or two and I think
that is a need regardless of where you
are on the introversion extraversion
dimension of personality and we could
have a whole separate podcast on the
science the latest science of
introversion because I'm super super
interested in that topic and I've
written a lot about it but I think
that's that's actually a separate
dimension that that dimension of
personality has more to do with your
levels of assertiveness and your levels
of enthusiasm or what's called positive
positive emotions that are of the of the
the high kind so I think like introverts
can have contentedness and calmness but
you find extroverts tend to report
higher levels of these other kinds of
static states you know all the time and
ok and and also assertiveness so my
connection that's need it's more about
having you know a small number of really
solid connections stable a minimal
number of just minimal number of stable
and an intimate so mutual relatedness
there's a relatedness aspect to it
that's very good and the third need
within the whole the boat is self esteem
and you did put the word self in there
yes I just one more thing about
introverts yeah you could be the most
you know introversion doesn't track anti
sociology so this is a common
misconception alright you know yeah and
I know you know that you know I want to
make that this is what I think this is
separate from this basic need I mean if
we're talking something else if you have
this extreme sort of version of any
human connection well then I think
there's something else going on with you
which we could talk about later dark
triads stuff but yeah that's not
introversion good well so maybe that's
what introversion is not when you tell
us what introversion is oh boy well that
this is why this is so caught this is so
hotly contested because scientists have
a different view of what introversion is
from what everyday people on the
internet who identify themselves
self-identify as introverts think of
themselves so on the internet if you ask
most people the nervous will say well
it's how I recharge my batteries you
know they'll say it's you know do I get
energized by people or not energized by
people well scientists view it more in
terms of the levels of dopamine okay and
and social reward so it's it's more
simply a matter in the scientific
literature of if you're an introvert you
simply get less reward from social
information or from social rewards like
and and that conclude things like the
possibility of getting esteem from
person a person you're talking to or
what you know not like being excited for
lots of novel social situations that's
why you tend to find that introverts
tend to prefer a couple close people
then going and networking with a million
people it's because when you network
with million people your dopamine system
is more activated than your oxytocin
system and and I think it's just simply
a matter physiologically introverts
don't get as much dopamine release at
the possibility for social reward with
novel social encounters
I think that's technically all it all
that dimension means okay since it does
but now is there and now I need a word
for the feature that I need to be alone
to get have time to recharge my
batteries I mean there are some people
who are energized by being out in public
and there's some people who are you know
the energy seeps away when they're
putting the effort to do that but if you
view it as a dopamine thing though it
which is what's really going on then it
you can map it on to that in a way
because dopamine predicts how much
effort we are motivated to put into
something so if we're not getting a lot
of dopamine push for something it
actually will take greater effort it'll
be more exhausting to put in the energy
to do something okay so wait yes so
they're not wrong so that metaphor of
the of the recharge battery thing it can
roughly be explained physiologically
through what we know about the dopamine
system as you have to work harder like
introverts would have to put in more
effort to be motivated and to to to talk
to lots and lots of people right and and
and you could see how it would be
exhausting to them quicker the next
reverbs yeah however I mean I did I
wrote a paper showing that there there's
some misconceptions here because there's
been some studies showing that both
introverts and extroverts do get tired
extroverts do get tired from from at a
certain point we're just talking about
thresholds that's all personality is
we're all human you know we're all and
this is a big point in my book we're all
human we can get too stuck on these
different types personality types not
realizing that look you could talk to
extroverts and they would still be
able to resonate with that feeling of
yes I've talked to too many people today
I need to sleep okay there are human too
there are human too so we're really just
talking about thresholds and I think
that it can be explained physiologically
through the dopamine system and how we
know don't mean when you have isn't it
open it could be an energizing force do
you know I mean for things that are
possibility of rewards mm-hmm yeah good
okay I think that does clear something
up that's very useful okay and it's
certainly separate from your notion of
connection so let's move on to self
esteem that's the third okay need right
there in the whole of the boat so what
do you mean by that
so self esteem is and I talked okis on a
healthy self esteem having us which has
two components a healthy sense of self
worth of I'm good enough it doesn't mean
that I'm better than others and I go
great pains to distinguish self esteem
from narcissism because there are
different things and they have different
developmental pathways
it's just I'm worthy and the second
component of self of a healthy self
esteem is mastery or some people call it
self competence or even just competence
just or self efficacy a generalized form
of self efficacy so across all the
different areas of my life I feel a
general sense of I'm in control of my
life I'm the driver of this life I can
do things I can make things happen
I have agency and the self worth part is
not just about agency it is it is a
distinguishable component from
competence so with self-worth it's more
tied to social relations and Maya valued
social partner we tend to tie our
self-worth to the two being viewed as a
social partner as well as liking or
liking ourselves some people actually
will call that component in the
psychological sure they'll call itself
liking versus self and competence and
they can actually come apart these two
forms of self esteem you can so for
instance those who score very very high
in narcissism tend to feel a great sense
of competence almost an exact and
exaggerated sense but they don't
actually like they don't actually like
themselves that much this
fascinating error voltage yeah that kind
of narcissist
you can't even her self well IV it yes
it yeah exactly that's so funny
well they they can fully admit
especially grandiose narcissist and I
actually distinguish between different
types of narcissists I tell you I'm
really nerdy so like you know I could
distinguish between vulner more
vulnerable quiet introverted form of
narcissism from the more braggy
Braca dosa or whatever that you know
form of an arson but but grandiose
narcissist they and they have such an
inflated sense of their competence but
if you do these kinds of even implicit
self-esteem measures and you have
measures like I'm a good person
or I'm a good I'm a valued social
partner or I like myself but I think I'm
you know I like myself I'm a they're
kind of neutral to negative on that
aspect alright yes that's good to know
we'll keep that it's helpful knowledge
when we meet narcissists to go like yeah
you probably are not happy with yourself
but okay so that's security we have it
we have it sussed right the the water
that our boat floats in and the boat
itself are a story of safety and
connection and self-esteem but you're
you're kind of you know as important as
those things are you really get juiced
up what we start talking about the sail
and how we can move and how we can do
things that the growth aspect of all
this that's exactly right
the meso called it the growing tip you
know when you have a tree there's a
certain portion of the tree that grows
much much more than the other parts of
the tree mm-hmm and I always like that
metaphor of the growing tip that was
kind of brilliant but yeah I'm really
interested in what are these
potentialities within us in humans that
really help us grow and and evolve as a
species and in your first one you again
once again have three needs that we
associate with this sale the first one
is exploration so what does that mean
that's right you could in a way is view
these this whole thing is to two
different triangles
two different two different hierarchies
when you're pitched in the state of
security and that's your whole world
that basis is safety but when you're in
the growth realm of human existence so
you can actually have two different
realms of human existence I don't know
if you can do that I didn't know you can
have the you know the deprivation form
of you know existence where everything
becomes about you trying to impart on
the world you know like you're making
demands in the world like feed me yeah
love me respect me but when you're in
the growth realm of existence which is
the realm were entering now in this
conversation the base of that is
exploration hmm so you're no longer
everything is not pivoting around the
need to to resolve a deprivation now
everything revolves around a general
spirit of actively entering the unknown
right you can exist from moment to
moment but you're gonna seek out some
new experiences correct you're excited
by the unknown as opposed to fearing it
intensely which is what you know
psychological entropy is all about well
actually let's let's talk about
psychological entropy because I just had
oh I know there's my thing but I had a
very interesting conversation with Karl
Freeston the neuroscientist who has a
whole theory of free energy and so forth
and it gets very technical but the the
very short version is that he thinks
that brains and even organisms work to
model the world in such a way so as to
minimize the surprise that they
experience and of course one question
was you know but we seek out surprise
all the time like we we do explore we do
read mystery novels or whatever and his
answer to that which I thought was
interesting was that it's secretly a
strategy on the part of the brain to
anticipate the future so be surprised
now so that you have a more complete and
flexible model of the world so as to
minimize the total amount of surprise
integrated over your future life do you
think that makes sense I do I think that
the the the need for exploration evolved
as a need all on its own
but it primarily as a reducing function
so I think that's consistent with what
what he just what he said and also by
the way I could solder these folks I had
Skype chats with this whole whole group
a lot of these people who studied the
physics of entry of entropy and trying
to apply it to the brain and I think
that I could make and I hope I did make
a good case in the book for the need for
exploration having its own evolved
function and not being reduced to the
need for safety or anxiety but I do
think it evolved in order to help us
with that anxiety reducing functioning
it helps you know the more that we can
prepare ahead of time and the more that
we can reduce that uncertainty by
actively seeking information so I really
connect the need for exploration with
with the information seeking aspects of
dopamine so there's some recent research
distinguishing between the social
aspects of dopamine or the more of what
are called appetitive rewards cocaine
sex you know status and there are
dopamine pathways they get us we're
really excited the possibility of those
things and they're our listeners that
when I said those three things they're
exactly brain they're brain is
particularly released it's just
releasing the dopamine in the synapses
like in mofo but there are also and I
suspect a lot of your listeners who just
by with the nerdier we get in this
conversation they also are releasing
dopamine into other dopamine projections
more related to the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex and I think that's a
really interesting new line of research
in understanding how there might be
dopamine pathways that give us
excitement the possibility of
information not just the possibility for
mating opportunities so you're saying
that equations lead to degrees yes I do
I think that there's a there's some good
there's there's some there's some
suggestive evidence that that that that
may be a separate pathway and I think it
can still be debated and we're still
trying to understand is it really just
the same pathways but there's individual
differences and etc in in there's
there's ways that this can be argued but
I think that it is possible to there are
there are different pathways there are
families that project
specifically to the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex and our working memory
that gives us excitement when our
working memory is active with with with
things that may give us greater
information to survive and I think this
is your next book right here you know
why mass releases dopamine like this is
absolutely killer there's I know people
who would buy this book Scott I'm
telling you but also it makes me wonder
about there are since we're talking
about the uniqueness of different
individuals there are absolutely people
who hate being in a routine and there
are absolutely other people who love
being in a routine right there are
people who love having a job where you
get to wear the same uniform every day
and there's other people who would find
that you know inner torment so how do we
distinguish between those people how do
we give them both space to be valid well
great this is a great point this is
where we get to the realm of individual
differences and as I talked about in the
need for safety chapter there are people
who may be the high in neuroticism
personality trait high in herbs they
have obsessive-compulsive disorder out
of our high level or or other things
that give them a intense need to control
the world and that may be a more
pressing need for them than the need for
exploration and I've spent you know
maybe 10 years of my career studying the
personality trait openness to experience
right which predicts you know to the
extent to which neuroticism predicts
then the need for security openness to
experiences predicts the need for
exploration I think these are these are
elements in the big five personality
inventory right correct correct they're
just mentioned two of the big five and
we already went deep into the
extraversion introversion one so which
other ones we have left to discuss today
we can't concentrate and we haven't
talked about grit conscientiousness and
we haven't talked about agreeableness
being a good person although we did kind
of talk about a little bit yeah yeah but
your question your is good and and I
wanted to make it clear that while these
are all basic well these are all needs
of humans we do differ quite a bit in it
at different points in our life how
pressing they are for us so I think
regardless of our personality I think
contextually as well these things these
needs could a band flow but also based
on our own temperament we can these
needs can can eventhough there are some
people that really do
I think Jeanette you know genetics plays
a role here care a lot more about being
belonging and yeah an intimacy but I
think that the lesson of what you're
saying here is that I mean exploration
is important as a part of this growth
aspect of the needs but it is something
where you don't try to just push it to
the maximum you don't be surprised every
moment of your life there is a an
appropriate amount of newness and
newness to experience and exploration
for any one person given who they are
and what they're interested in yes I
really do think that any fully
functioning system requires both safety
and growth security and growth and and
also there's been other labels like I
used earlier like stability and
plasticity but I think any fully
function system is going to have to
reconcile with with both at some point
in their life good okay the next need on
our sale is love so you uh so it's
interesting because you're putting love
here in the growth part of the needs not
in the security part yeah I did and I
wanted to separate so one thing I did as
I separate belonging from intimacy
within the need for connection but the
other thing I wanted to do is I wanted
to separate an unconditional form of
love a higher spiritual form of love
entirely from connection I wanted to get
it out I wanted to get it out of the
boat and into the sail and into the sail
because when you project that in your
sail you can do that to anyone it
doesn't have to be those only the people
you like or only the people you feel a
sense of relatedness to so there's more
cosmetic aspect to love yes absolutely
it's an attitude love is an attitude not
necessarily a feeling
in fact you could hate someone if in
terms of what the feeling you know label
we put hate on the on that feeling but
still have be loved and this is what
Maslow talk called be love love for the
being of others and the sacredness of
others even if they're different from
who are being is we can just admire
people for who they are not what we're
trying to get out of them or what they
can do usefulness they have for us right
even in the even at the level of
connection it's still about usefulness
you know it you know you're still making
demands and people to connect with me
mmm-hmm but at the be love level of
human existence you don't make those
sorts of demands it's more that you're
offering something to the world rather
than just asking things of it that's
right okay and and then the third need
in the sale is purpose and this is the
one I want to talk about the most but oh
oh because I have my doubts but I want
to hear your sales pitch first so I
can't wait to hear your I know because
it's important one to you I know
well I wouldn't actually say it's the
most important if you actually asked me
to choose I may actually choose like
transcendency which we're going in a
second you know but but but purpose the
point I wanted to make there is if I had
to choose I would choose the integration
of them all then yeah yeah yeah that's
that's that's like that's like the
spoiler totally okay go ahead yeah yeah
yeah but but purpose is it's a tough one
to define although I do have a precise
definition in the book how did I define
it the need for purpose can be defined
as the need for an overarching
aspiration that energizes one's efforts
and provides a central source of meaning
and significance in one's life the way I
think about purpose and we can have
multiple purposes but it's a more
superordinate goal and it it serves as
an organizing framework so to speak for
all of our other goals so that we can
see if our other goals in our hierarchy
maybe it less abstract levels or broad
levels of abstraction
are working together as a whole unit in
making sure that we're realizing that
highest level goal or aspiration or one
could just colloquially called a dream
dream if we've lost everyone and what I
just said we say just having a dream you
know a really broad dream making sure
that we really can reach it to our full
capacity that we're not having things
that are taking away unnecessarily from
our capacity to realize that dream but I
don't get your thoughts well I
completely agree that having a purpose
of the form that you talk about can
really help right can really give
somebody momentum direction and
fulfillment in their lives but but I
have a bunch of questions one of which
is do we really need that I mean can
people be just as happy without some
sort of big picture future goal in mind
can can there be no more living in the
moment without necessarily having a
purpose and can that be just as
rewarding Oh animal uh this is a
legitimate question it's not like a
leading question like I'm open to
whatever the answer might be so yes and
it's a terrific terrific question it's
one that I had quite a bit back and
forth with Ken and Sheldon who did a lot
of the research that I tried to
synthesize in that chapter he doesn't
talk about he doesn't use the word
purpose he talks about self concordant
goals the importance of setting the
right goals that will lead to growth and
I when I told him I was kind of frame
this in terms of purpose and everything
he was very skeptical of that and he you
know he said well like I teach my
students don't worry about this purpose
is so dramatic so dramatic and daunting
you know you know there I'm also can be
a bit of a dramatic person too so the
surface yeah resonates more with my
being you know like yeah like there's
there's something exciting and thrilling
about about about having a superordinate
goal that that gives you like a
hierarchy of meaning in your life you
know they're like I think it's fair to
say there are some goals you have that
give you a deeper sense of meaning than
other goals you know like the goal to
just get out of
it is not is not your purpose in life
you know but it smell this is where I
mean this is what I if I were to be more
playing the devil's advocate which I
sometimes try to do you know in the
podcast context you know one of the
criticisms against Maslow was that it
was a little elitist his conception of
psychology right like he was looking at
the people who had been most successful
in lives successful I would correct you
there he didn't he did not equate
self-actualization with achievement okay
but he was looking at people like Gandhi
and Einstein and so forth right I mean
he was not looking at people who he met
randomly on the street
that's a fair point that's a fair point
although he he I saw an interview with
is a very precious interview with his
wife Bertha after Maseo died and they're
interviewing you know her about how they
thought about self-actualization and she
said you know he really thought my
mother was self actualized was me way
more self actualized and he thought he
himself was and his and and his his
mother was really a good a good kind her
her mother was a good kind person but
not a not someone who had achieved a lot
yeah and if you actually look at
Maslow's writings he started off the
whole idea of self actually and he
started what's called what he called the
good human being notebook he was just
taking down notes of who he thought were
the the best specimens of humanity in
the sense that they were good people and
I think that gets lost a lot in in in
this notion of self-actualization and
actually the spirit upon which he went
into this he thought that self actualize
people represent what's best in humanity
but not but he did not equate it with
high achievement okay the feticide
Maslow's individual thoughts aside I I
think that there is a danger because
it's not so I mean for you it might have
been Maslow for me when I think about
people in moral philosophy for example
like John Stuart Mill trying to make
distinctions between higher and lower
pleasures or people who talk about the
meaning of life and they associate it
with you know some sort of creative work
or
changing the world in some way and all
of this sounds and you know I have those
goals and purposes myself but the idea
that that's what it should be does sound
a little bit elitist to me I think
there's plenty of space out there again
playing the devil's advocate for just
living for just saying like no I don't
wake up in the morning like with my
grand plan I just want to like be good
at the day and I can find meaningfulness
in the competency and compassion with
which I approach the everyday small
things and I if you if you want to say
well that counts as a purpose then
that's fine but I don't think it's what
people think of when you say the word
purpose mm-hmm
I think you're right and you know if you
want to talk about transcendence we do
but at some point there is a kind of a
there is a grand reveal or an accreta
feel there is a twit there's a twist
ending to this book yeah and I've been
holding off on it because it's like I
want people to read the boot but I you
know there is a twist ending and okay
you know it gets to get what do you say
okay M night Shyamalan in psychology no
no there that speaks directly to the
heart of what you're saying and and that
was a twist of Mazouz as well because he
thought it was all about self
actualization all about this grand
purpose and mission having a mission
outside your and self and then he faced
his own mortality and he suddenly didn't
care about any of that stuff anymore
right and it confused the heck out of
him and he wrote you know in his book
this is so strange that this experience
of mortality which is in a sense taken
me all the way to the bottom not of a
pyramid but you know made me focus on
this this lower need has actually
increased my sense of transcendence and
appreciation of the world more than I've
ever had in my entire life and has made
me care less about the the
competitiveness drive or the achievement
drive
the ego so this was a real paradox that
he was trying to work out and in the
last year and a half of his life before
he he did succumb to a heart attack at
the age of 62 suddenly you know you know
I think so yeah this is good I do want
to sort of I'm sorry about your book and
your dramatic instincts I want to
totally spoil at the ending of your book
here in the podcast and talk about
transcendence but I do have one more
question about purpose which is I think
sure no one that many people will have
which is where is it supposed to come
from I mean can it be completely
arbitrary does it matter which purpose
we have you know there there are people
here in the United States of America who
you know build the world's largest ball
of twine or something like that and is
that just as good as people who find a
cure for cancer oh just as good Wow well
that's that's a heavy question and and
and I would be the last one to start to
to just claim I'm the arbitrator of oh
boy that's something but I want to
emphasize that this is an integrated
hierarchy of needs yeah we can't view
any one of these as separate from the
whole system or the whole sailboat and
and and and I've really thought this out
I really thought this out in a very in a
very very OCD level but you know if
we're talking about building purpose on
a foundation of expiration and love
that's the way of being that I think
leads to the transcendence that I'm
talking about yeah and I'm not talking
about a purpose that's that's being
driven by your deprivation needs like
ego and and the desperate needs to
fulfill a hole within yourself I do
think that it we can call purpose we can
call it just a deep deep or a goal that
gives us a deep sense of satisfaction
when we work toward it if that if that's
fine we can get let's get rid of that we
for the purposes of this conversations
just so we're on the same page we can
get rid of the word purpose and we just
talk about a
a dream a spur an overarching aspiration
or or even just a goal that is higher
priority of meaning for us than other
goals yeah
even just that even just add the basic
level and you combine that with a sense
of exploration and a sense of be love
for Humanity it's being driven by a
spirit of wanting to make the broader
world a better place I think those three
things work as a whole unit in allowing
us to transcend ourselves and that's the
point I wanted to make in the book good
I mean maybe let's uh let's focus more
specifically in on transcendence you
know when I read that party book I
thought of the Zen story about the monk
who was asked you know what is the
difference in his life before and after
he became enlightened stop me if you've
heard this one but he said well you know
before I came in before I became
enlightened I would chop wood and carry
water and now that I'm enlightened I
chop wood and carry water that's it
that's the whole story in some way to
the idea of transcending the you know
I'm sure that he's sort of the idea was
he conceptualized and received it and
got a different kind of satisfaction
from it post enlightenment but his stuff
that he was doing to get through the day
was just the same stuff that's exactly
that's right that's very well and I do
love that I talk about healthy
transcendence as different from
unhealthy transcendence so there's a lot
of this is an overarching framework for
everything in life by the way I think
everything in life is neither good or
bad it has a deprivation flavor to it
and a growth flavor to it and that can
apply to anything you start to view the
world that way I think it really opens
your eyes up to a lot you know you can
have deprivation humor but you can which
is very self-deprecating and or maybe
aggressive towards others but you can
have a more growth for growth oriented
form of humor
you can have a form of aggression that
is very deprivation motivated but you
can have kind of the Martin Luther King
kind of aggression which is like we're
gonna use this to uplift all of humanity
you can go down the line you know and I
think the same applies to transcendence
I think you have a deprivation form of
transcendence which you see in the world
today with
these so-called gurus who who claim to
be above humanity they're like I so I'm
asking all the curse about trying to
piss up all the gurus here but I'm
saying there are some that you see they
abused their position of power you see
that they they sort of have this it's
it's being it's being motivated clearly
as I see it through narcissism and and
through these these these security needs
not through growth through growth but I
do think there's a form of healthy
transcendence that sits that's well
integrated and and is not about being
above humanity but it's about being a
part of humanity as much as possible and
I think that's very that's different
those are different conceptualizations
of what transcendence means and the kind
I'm talking about is a is a sense of
great great connectedness to the rest of
humanity just by being who you are I'm
not saying that it's you are sacrificing
yourself there's a higher level of
integration where at the highest level
of integration there's a seamlessness
between you and the world
hello I'm actually gonna stop on that
okay no no that's that's very good the
seamlessness between you in the world I
think is very powerful image yeah and
maybe in fact it answers the question I
was just going to ask which is the word
transcend or transcendence kind of begs
a question about what is it that we are
transcending and do you have a simple
answer to that is it a thing that we
were transcending or is it more vague
than that well one could at the most
simplistic level say you're transcending
the ego mm-hmm okay good and then and
then that's a very simplistic way of
saying and then when we say well what is
the ego and and I would define the ego
could be defined in a million different
ways and then and then the self has a
million different definitions but for
purposes of our conversation one could
define the ego as all those aspects of
ourselves that are the defensive aspects
of ourselves are the ones that tie us to
security as much as possible and to
the relief from risk and the potential
for pain
it's our defense mechanisms mm-hmm so in
a lot of ways it it really is
transcending no longer needing no longer
needing our needs got a way so that it's
the needs that are being transcended or
the need for our needs right that's a
better way of saying it yeah correct
correct
okay very good good is that is that
people should read your book to find out
more I don't want them to think they
learned everything there's a long book
full of footnotes and a lot more detail
than we were able to get into here thank
you I appreciate that there is there's
more but you've really given me quite
the opportunity here today to to really
get I hope not in the weeds no believe
me I'm gonna get a million comments on
YouTube saying thank you for going into
the weeds more weed oh good I surely
hope that people and do you know like to
listen to us kind of nerd out at this
level and that they can gain value from
that because this is not your I realized
this is not your kind of self-help book
that I'm just telling you the five steps
to lead a better life and I do have an
appendix of exercises but I die I think
and I that there are enough people out
there that don't want to just be told
what to do they they want to know the
theory be and science behind it and I
try to balance both those things but
let's make it clear for potential
readers I mean in the book and also on
your website you do have actual specific
actionable items that people can do to
try to help themselves transcend in the
sense you're talking about right I do
and a lot of these things I adapted from
exercises I called them growth
challenges that have my students do I
teach a course on the science of living
well and you see I see transformations
this is not only tested through science
in a formally peer-reviewed journal
articles through a hundred and hundreds
of students who have said that the this
way of thinking about the world and
these kinds of exercises have helped
them grow and transcend themselves
in in in in powerful ways and and these
exercises are also a lot of them are not
your standard sort of happiness
exercises because happiness is not my
goal here
my goal is growth so yeah it's this is
this is gonna be deflationary but I love
the story in your book about Maslow
moving to Brandeis and you know teaching
the class and that at the end like the
end of the semester one of the students
says is this gonna be on the test can
you tell me what's gonna be in the final
and he's like you've learned nothing
from anything that I've told you all
this course and ironically that happened
to be in my class of course and I
couldn't help but then relay the story
of Maslow and I get that student I
didn't appreciate well of course you
also have a podcast
let the tell people on your podcast so
they know about that sure so I have
something I have a podcast called the
psychology podcast it's great that we
will still to sort of you'll get that
name before anyone else did I got it
very I got yeah now others have to try
to steal mine but I didn't steal
anything you didn't steal it you know I
know I know you were there first
I was there first and I it's just such a
great opportunity for me to find the
leading psychologists maybe even names
of psychologists that that that aren't
the household psychologist names but I
could still give them a platform because
I still think they're leading and
they're doing great stuff and discussing
all aspects of the human mind and human
nature I and the human variation I
nothing nothing's off off off limits
with you up for discussion respectfully
and compassionately on my podcast so
that's been great great fun I really
hope I think a lot I'd really do believe
a lot of the listeners of your podcast
it would enjoy some of the episodes if
not a lot of the episodes of my podcast
yeah no I think it's a great thought and
a great place to end on Scott Barry
Kaufman thanks so much for be on the
mindscape podcast thank you for having
me on it's been great
[Music]
you
[Music]